So if I were giving advice to someone who wants to work in the field of soft robotics,
I would say that learning robotics is already a very, very multi-disciplinary thing.
So you know your mechanical,
you know your electrical,
you know your software,
you know, there's all these skills you need to take on.
So, easy enough take on a few more.
Who doesn't like learning?
So, learn about your chemistries particularly your polymer chemistries.
Learn about chemical engineering and the way in which manufacturers convert
raw chemical materials into
sophisticated mechanical constructs and electrical constructs.
Also learn about biomechanics.
There are some of the greatest machines ever created are found in nature.
Natural systems do things incredibly efficiently with minimal computation
relative to what's seen in the robots that we as a society build today.
So I would heavily encourage people to
learn a lot more about biological systems to draw inspiration,
to create inspired new mechanisms.